el cirujano realizará una cirugía de
glaucoma para fijar problemas de drenaje
en el ojo debido a la alta presión
intraocular
la cámara anterior se llena con un
líquido acuoso llamado humor acuoso que
baña y nutre la córnea y la lente cuando
el humor acuoso fluye desde la cámara
posterior continuamente drena a través
de la red trabecular entre el iris y la
córnea el flujo adecuado del humor
acuoso mantiene la presión dentro del
ojo normalmente balanceada
cuando se produce el glaucoma el humor
acuoso drena hacia fuera demasiado lento
o es producido demasiado rápido
originando la acumulación del líquido
que incrementa la presión intraocular
con la atención de esta presión las
fibras del nervio óptico se dañan y con
el tiempo mueren lo que puede producir
la pérdida de visión permanente las
opciones de cirugía de glaucoma incluyen
los procedimientos con láser y sin láser
el procedimiento dura por lo general
entre 10 y 60 minutos
si se somete a un procedimiento láser se
deberá sentar con el rostro mirando
hacia la máquina láser se le
administrarán gotas oftálmicas para
adormecer el ojo se colocará un pequeño
dispositivo en los ojos para mantener
los párpados abiertos
una trabeculoplastia es un procedimiento
láser que aumenta el drenaje de líquido
desde la red trabecular durante una
trabe culo plástica láser el médico
usará una lente de contacto especial
sostenida sobre el frente del ojo para
enfocar un rayo de luz láser en la red
trabecular
si el procedimiento tiene éxito ello
permitirá que fluya más líquido del ojo
lo que disminuirá la presión intraocular
una herodoto mía periférica es un
procedimiento láser que abre un ángulo
de drenaje estrecho o cerrado entre la
córnea y el iris este ángulo cerrado
interfiere con el drenaje del líquido en
este procedimiento
el médico utilizará el láser para
realizar un pequeño orificio en el iris
lo que permitirá que el líquido fluya
más libremente dentro del ojo
la ciclo fotocoagulación es un
procedimiento láser que reduce la
producción de humor acuoso
en la ciclo fotocoagulación el médico
usará un láser para destruir partes del
cuerpo ciliar que produce humor acuoso
si tiene éxito reducirá la producción de
líquido y disminuirá la presión del ojo
una trabe colectomía es una cirugía
incisión al que extrae una parte de la
red trabecular del ojo durante este
procedimiento el médico utilizará
pequeños instrumentos para extraer
diminutos trozos de tejido de la pared
del ojo dejando un pequeño orificio a
través del cual el humor acuoso puede
drenar hacia afuera y ser re absorbido
en el flujo sanguíneo
aunque los medicamentos y los
tratamientos quirúrgicos puedan ayudar a
prevenir futuras pérdidas de visión no
pueden reparar la visión que se perdió
debido al glaucoma
luego del procedimiento usted será
controlado durante una o dos horas antes
de retirarse se le colocará un parche
ocular o vendas para usar temporalmente
se le recetara gotas oftálmicas y se le
indicará cómo utilizar las probablemente
el médico le aconseje mantener el ojo
seco durante un tiempo evitar nadar o
bañarse y dejar de manejar temporalmente
levantar peso o esforzarse